es gibt neue spannende Entwicklungen in
Russland nach dem Tod des russischen
söldnerchefs pregorian soll nun das
ehemalige Wagner Führungsmitglied andre
trozev neue freiwilligen Kampfverbände
aufbauen so will es Putin und auf seinen
Willen hin wurde folgendes Video heute
vor wenigen Stunden veröffentlicht das
zeigt den russischen Präsidenten beim
Briefing im Kreml und hier rechts im
Bild andre trojev ein ehemaliger kann
man Dörr der Wagner Truppe nun holt
Protein also ins
Verteidigungsministerium ist 61 Jahre
alt und Kampf erprobt der grauhaarige
lässt er sich nennen bei dem Treffen mit
dabei Vize Verteidigungsminister Yunus
Beck yes
ist der neue pregorian wir wollen über
diesen interessanten Schachzug des
russischen Präsidentin Putins sprechen
mit dem militär-experten und Russland
Kenner Niko lange einen schönen guten
Tag Grüße nach Berlin hallo Herr Lange
Putin sagt bei diesem Treffen extra für
die Kameras Frau Schiff sei Kriegs
erprobt kriegserfahren er wisse was zu
tun sei damit Zitat die Kampfeinsätze
auf bestem und erfolgreichster Weise
erledigt werden was heißt das wer ist
dieser Tasche Chef
ist einer der Kommandeure aus dem
kommandeursrat der wagnergruppe und
einer der wenigen die überlebt haben
nachdem er die gesamte Führungsriege mit
dem Flugzeug abgestürzt ist und
offensichtlich hat das
Verteidigungsministerium ist jetzt
geschafft Herrn treuev einzubinden und
gleichzeitig ist diese ganze Aktion ja
ein Zugeständnis das Putin und das
russische verteilungsministerium die
Wagner Söldner brauchen in der Ukraine
wo sie ja im Süden und auch bei bachmut
unter Druck stehen und jetzt
offensichtlich wieder unter dem Decken
Mantel es seien freiwillige diese Wagner
sollten dorthin bringen wollen
nun hat Putin man könnte sagen ja schon
auch ein gewisses Fable für tranchef
gehabt nachdem der Putschversuch von
gescheitert war hatte er ihn so ins
Gespräch gebracht allerdings hat
Brigitte
als Nachfolger abgelehnt wie können Sie
dieses Verhältnis Putin traf beschreiben
hat ja aus gutem Grund seine engsten
Kommandeure und seinen Stellvertreter
immer bei sich behalten auch in diesem
Flugzeug dann am Ende weil er wusste
dass der Kreml und das
verteilungsministerium daran arbeiten da
Leute rauszubrechen und mit denen zu
arbeiten um das Geschäft der
wagnergruppe selbst zu übernehmen und um
auch die Söldner und die Führung über
die Söldner selbst zu organisieren
offensichtlich hat der Kreml schon
länger an Frau Chef gearbeitet
vielleicht gab es da auch schon länger
Verbindungen im Hintergrund und hat auf
diesen Mann gesetzt und jetzt mit dem
Absturz von seiner Führungsmannschaft
ist der Weg dafür frei diesen Plan
umzusetzen
ich zitiere jetzt noch mal was Putin
eben gesagt hat treucht jetzt sei der
richtige um diese Dinge zu erledigen was
ist also zu befürchten oder zu erwarten
sie haben selber schon gesagt wenn diese
neuen von trottchef dann wohl
aufgebauten freiwilligen Kampf verwendet
zum Beispiel in bachmut eben in der
Ukraine dann aktiv werden
macht was völlig anderes als er direkt
nach dem gescheiterten Putschversuch
angekündigt hat es hieß ja die Wagner
Söldner sollten sich entweder in die
Streitkräfte integrieren oder nach Hause
gehen oder in Belarus sein in Belarus
sind glaube ich nicht mehr viele einige
sind wieder nach Afrika gegangen andere
wussten nicht so richtig was sie machen
und jetzt ist der Plan offenbar die
Wagner Söldner unter dem neuen Label es
sein freiwillige doch wieder in die
Ukraine zu bringen und sie dort kämpfen
zu lassen also mir scheint Putin hat er
keinen großen Plan sondern er
improvisiert immer so wie die Lage das
eben hergibt und muss jetzt eben etwas
anderes tun als der ursprünglich dachte
es hat natürlich den Kreml sehr geholfen
dass das Flugzeug abgestürzt ist das
pregorian die gesamte Führungsmannschaft
aus dem Weg sind weil viele Wagner
seltener jetzt in gewisser Weise
orientierungslos waren und dass man
jetzt so öffentlich zeigt mit Putin soll
ja all diesen sört dann auch zeigen wer
jetzt der neue Chef ist und dass der
neue Chef den Segen Putin hat
und dass der Vize Verteidigungsminister
mit am Tisch sitzt ist das ein
deutliches Zeichen das aber eben diese
ist aber neue wagnertruppe die aber
jetzt eben freiwilligen Kampfverbände
angeführt von troschev sein werden dass
die aber doch sehr klar an das
Verteidigungsministerium gekoppelt sein
werden das ist der entscheidende Punkt
Putin selbst hat das ja auch so
formuliert dass der Traumschiff bereits
im Verteidigungsministerium tätig sein
man hat nicht gesagt was er da genau
macht dabei hat er offensichtlich jetzt
einen Job im verteilungsministerium und
man kann sagen dass das System Scheu gut
der war zwar nicht da aber das System
scheuburg das verteilungsministers hat
sich am Ende durchgesetzt die
wagnergruppe wird jetzt da eng
eingebunden und kann nicht mehr so
selbstständig und so eigenständig stark
agieren wie das Unterbringung in der
Fall war
sagen sie noch mal ein Wort zu dem Vize
Verteidigungsminister jefkurow den wir
eben auch im Bild gesehen haben als
prägogin den Aufstand gestartet hat da
gab es ja eine sehr interessante
Begegnung zwischen den beiden vielleicht
können Sie das auch noch mal beschreiben
ist schon länger jemand der als
stellvertretender verteilungsminister
also es gibt mehrere Stellvertreter er
ist eben einer davon aber der als
stellvertretender verteilungsminister
die Arbeit der privaten Militärfirmen
auch der Firma Wagner überwacht und
koordiniert der deswegen auch ein
eigenes Verhältnis hatte zum Beispiel zu
Herrn und es gab ja bei der Erstürmung
oder der Besetzung dieses Hauptquartiers
in Rostock am Don bei den Putschversuch
Bilder wo die beiden relativ
einträchtigen nebeneinander saßen und
offensichtlich mit Ihrem Telefon darauf
warteten dass sie da in Moskau und was
hören aber hey ihr konnte eigentlich
auch nur sagen na ja der Rassismus und
scheuburg sind weg und Krieg aus den hat
daraufhin dann seine Leute nach Moskau
geschickt ihr kuroff ist auch derjenige
der jetzt in der gesamten Zeit seit dem
Flugzeugabsturz und teilweise auch schon
davor die afrikanischen Länder bereist
hat in denen die wagnergruppe aktiv ist
da ist ja das lukrative Kerngeschäft der
wagnergruppe weil man mit diesen
Dienstleistungen wenn man das so nennen
will die die wagnergruppe in Afrika
erbringt also Diktatoren zu beschützen
da Truppen auszubilden
Zugänge zu legalen und illegalen Handel
mit Rohstoffen mit Diamanten mit Gold
mit vielen anderen attraktiven Dingen
eröffnet werden und die Kontrolle über
dieses Geschäft zu gewinnen das war ja
eine ganz entscheidende Frage nach
diesem Putsch und nach dem Ausschalten
von pregorian und auch da ist eben
dieser stellvertretende
verteilungsminister sehr aktiv und dass
die wagnergruppe in Afrika wieder sehr
Person mit sehr vielen Personen aktiv
ist da gab es ja schon länger Berichte
darüber und das ist ja noch mal deutlich
geworden gerade vor wenigen Tagen wo
eine il 76 Transport Maschine in Gau
über die Landebahn hinausgeschossen ist
und ausgebrannt ist und man später
festgestellt hat das war eine Maschine
die war zwar auch mit malischen Truppen
besetzt aber die war vor allen Dingen
voller wagnerkämpfer was bedeutet das
sie sagen jeff kurof ist auch dahin
gereist um deutlich zu machen oder dafür
zu sorgen dass die Aktivitäten wirklich
strikt dann dort unter Kontrolle des
Verteidigungsministeriums sind was ist
denn jetzt zu erwarten wenn wir auf
diese Aktivitäten in Afrika schauen es
ist zu erwarten dass das was das
Geschäftsmodell der wagnergruppe war
weitergeführt wird wie dann diese
Gruppierung heißt ist im Grunde
irrelevant aber das sind Leistungen die
so eine militärfirma erbringt die von
offiziellen Streitkräften nicht erbracht
werden können so ist wagnergruppe ja
auch mal entstanden als verlängerte Arm
des russischen Militärgeheimdienstes die
können dort alle möglichen Dinge tun
sozusagen dreckiges Geschäft erledigen
und im Gegenzug eben Zugang gewinnen
Dingen die Reichtum versprechen
Rohstoffe andere Dinge und natürlich
auch Einfluss gewinnen über zum Beispiel
afrikanische
Diktatoren autoritäre Herrscher die man
dort beschützt um diese Staaten weiter
an der Seite Russlands zu halten dieses
Geschäft ist sehr wichtig und es wird
eben weitergeführt aber eben jetzt sehr
stark vom
verteilungsministerium überwacht man ist
offensichtlich im Kremmen und
verteilungsministerium ganz fest gewählt
zwar private Militärfirmen weiter zu
benutzen aber ihnen nicht mehr diese
Eigenständigkeit einzuräumen das wäre
jetzt meine Frage gewesen das Besondere
ist ja dass die wagnertruppe vom
militärischen Geheimdienst aufgebaut
worden ist sich aber dann irgendwie
unterbringhausen verselbstständig hat zu
einem Macht gegen Polen wurde zum
Verteidigungsministerium zu
Verteidigungsminister Scheu GU und das
ja eben ganz kritische Sache wurde und
wie will Putin das jetzt verhindern sie
sagen also das sozusagen ganz klar von
vorne rein der neue Präsident der neue
Führer dieser freiwilligen Kampfverbände
so fest eingebunden wird in das
Verteidigungsministerium aber meinen sie
das wirklich auch funktionieren
Putin hat ja zuvor die Botschaft gesetzt
wer sich mit mir anlegt der stürzen mit
dem Flugzeug ab
diese Botschaft ist glaube ich
angekommen bei vielen Akteuren und es
gibt ja auch Leute die aus Fenstern
fallen und plötzliche Herzinfarkte
erleiden also ich glaube das ist jedem
klar der sich auf so etwas einlässt und
scheuge und das Verteidigungsministerium
haben jetzt im Grunde Vertrauensleute
die diese Dinge führen man muss abwarten
wie wichtig denn diese Söldner am Ende
in der Ukraine werden weil der Schlüssel
zu pregorians Macht und Eigenständigkeit
war dass er mit der wagnergruppe und mit
10.000 in Kämpfern dort
skrupellos vorgegangen ist und damit
aber mehr erreicht hat an einigen Teilen
der Front als die russischen
Streitkräfte und dadurch ist er so
bedeutsam geworden und ist ja dann auch
für viele in Russland zu so einer Art
Held geworden der den wirklichen Kampf
kämpft und nahe bei den Soldaten ist das
kann man zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt aber
noch nicht beurteilen man wird
beobachten müssen was das eigentlich
heißt wenn jetzt diese sogenannten
freiwilligen Verbände unter
Koordinierung von Herrn droger in der
Ukraine eingesetzt werden möglicherweise
wieder in bachmut oder anderswo an der
Front
daraus ergibt sich ja bei mir
automatisch irgendwie die Frage wenn
Putin sagt er wird den Job erledigen
trottchev ist Kampf erprobt wenn sie
sagen im Grunde haben das
Geschäftsmodell in Afrika wird gleich
bleiben und das Putin entgegen seiner
Ankündigung nach dem Putsch dann doch
wieder diese freiwilligen Kampfverbände
aufbauen lässt von Frau Chef und in die
Ukraine schicken wird ist mit der
gleichen Brutalität zu rechnen die die
Wagner Söldner eben unter pregorien an
den Tag gelegt haben davon kann man
ausgehen das sind die gleichen
ehemaligen Verbrecher das sind die
gleichen Leute die brutalste
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
Kriegsverbrechen begangen haben in der
Ukraine auch in Afrika auch in Syrien
und wenn diese Wagner sollten wir wieder
eingesetzt werden muss man damit rechnen
dass diese Grausamkeiten weitergehen
auch in der Ukraine
also ist möglicherweise damit zu rechnen
dass eben vieles beim Alten bleibt
Geschäftsmodell aber eben unter anderem
Vorzeichen sie haben es deutlich gemacht
dass eben dann der Anführer Frau Chef
doch anders eingebunden wird in die
Strukturen des verteilungsministeriums
sehr lange vielen vielen Dank für die
Einschätzungen anders eben das Video das
gezeigt hat wie Putin eben sozusagen den
Auftrag an den neuen pregorien eben
André Treff gegeben hat vielen Dank für
die Einschätzungen Informationen nach
Berlin und vielen Dank für das Interesse
tschüss